c'est la période de noël où
effectivement et noël c'est quand même
c'est quand même une fête de partage et
malavoi a toujours eu cette idée de
partager avec d'autres artistes
c'était la bonne batebi ce qu'on avait
fait en 92 c'est l'album marronnage
qu'on avait fait en 98
c'est l'album all your man on a fait il
ya deux ou trois ans avec toujours
l'idée de rencontres de rencontres
musicales de partage de musique tout
simplement
et moi je pense que par ailleurs ça fait
partie du rôle d'un groupe comme à la
vois quelque chose d'indémodables qui
est peu de chose qui fait partie du
patrimoine culturel martiniquais du
patrimoine historique martiniquais et
cette capacité qu'a ce groupe d'aller
vers d'autres de se renouveler en
permanence y compris à l'intérieur de
ses membres parce que je pense que le
mal à voir et quelque chose de plus fort
que chacun de ceux qui composent le
groupe et malavoi est quelque chose qui
peut durer at vitam aeternam
un peu comme les groupes cubains comme
comme des charmes la cubaine qui existe
encore aujourd'hui alors qu'elles sont
nées dans les années 20
pour moi c'est un monument et donc à
cette fête de partage
il y aura donc des artistes comme all
and comme marijosé alie et bien d'autres
il y aura effectivement orlan marie
josée et horreur pipeau lauriane zachary
bien sûr et puis voilà j'ai pas mal ça
va déjà s'occuper et puis je crois qu'il
va y avoir ce concert quelque chose de
un peu entre guillemets nouveau de très
anciens mais de très nouveau c'est à
dire que avec nicole bernard on a eu
l'idée tous les deux de que le groupe
joue antoine hissent sur scène un
morceau qui n'a jamais de jouer sur
scène sauf une fois en quatre mois à 3
ans guadeloupe
mais sinon ça un morceau qui est figure
sur l'album grill sur kelly avait
caressé - et qui a été enregistré
j'étais sorti remettra 1 3 et depuis le
groupe n'avait jamais joué entre nantua
10 sur scène donc laser quelque sorte
une première
35 ans après